well first things first the movie's not
even fully out yet and the critics are
already saying this is Rock Solid this
brings new life into the franchise all
of those good things how did those
positive reviews sit with you
um you know when when the masses haven't
even really seen it yet yeah
you know when reviews could start
happening we happen to be traveling all
together me Jonathan and Mike and and
there were folks on the plane with us
who also publicist so people are getting
some of it in real time you know what I
mean and I I think it was so nice to be
that across from Mike and looking at him
and just feel this tremendous amount of
pride it's not about what critics say
Obviously these movies I think first and
foremost are really for the audiences so
I think that's when it'll hit me is how
does it land with audiences that's who
we make them the the film for but I just
know you know there's a tremendous
amount of pressure for my coming into
the third installment and also coming in
as an actor there's this idea of like
can he can he direct yeah do it and so I
think that early sort of validation even
though we weren't reading the reviews
but we could tell from the faces of the
people around that it wasn't bad
we're just like looking at them we're
like okay yeah it didn't you know it
seemed to get lighter for a certain area
of folks that were reading things and I
just feel so proud looking at looking at
him and he's beaming you know yeah
because it it is I can only imagine the
pressure because it's also the first
film without Sylvester you know what I'm
saying and and he's pulling double duty
yeah which I know has to be tough how
was Michael the director as opposed to
him Michael reactor you know what's
funny is some of the things that Mike is
as a actor he really brought to
directing and you know it's interesting
when you've known someone for a really
long time you have this idea of them and
sometimes you have inclinations of of
things that they might be and I always
sense that he would be a good leader you
know um and it was really nice to have
my suspicion confirmed like as an actor
he's always been the kind of actor that
comes on set and people are genuinely
very happy to to see him which is not
always the case there are some very fine
actors they don't necessarily make
everyone happy when they come Mike is is
someone that does and so the fact that I
think he could could do that as a
director as well that he that he's
inside of making a very good film he's
also trying to make the experience of
making the film a very good one for the
people making it and that I think is
really unique I love the fact that you
all seamlessly like Incorporated ASL and
your life and the day-to-day and it
wasn't it didn't feel forced didn't feel
like it was it just felt very normal
like we're getting an inside look into
this everyday family's life I thought
that was so beautiful yeah really I
thought so too I think just to sort of
normalize those images is so impactful
and you know Mila who brilliantly plays
our daughter
she's truly a star like a really really
a star like never mind obviously
there'll be a lot of necessary
conversation around the representation
that she provides in the context of this
film never mind that she's extraordinary
just as a talent has that kind of
natural like it Whatever It Is she has
it
um so to have her around and then her
real family was with us her brilliant
mom Kim who was there every day with us
on set and getting just to see them in a
family that speaks exclusively in in ASL
and to be able to you know bring that
energy to screen and just say how
beautiful to project images of like like
this in this kind of film yeah she
really is a star I was like this one
here like watch out watch out
um okay so we see the three of you you
Michael and and Jonathan and of course
me being the MCU nerd I'm like what is
going on with my world I've got three
MCU vets here well Jonathan's about to
be he's about to be uh yeah he's about
to be a vet and then we have you know
you guys starring in this franchise do
you did you guys ever get a chance just
to sit on set and kind of talk about
them funny we never did we were so sort
of solidly in the pocket of what we were
making at the time that we weren't even
really thinking about that but it's
interesting like
um I it feels almost like Marvel has
this thing of creating this kind of
Ensemble you know like and so it is
really special that we get to also share
that I don't know if our paths were ever
crossed in the NCAA you but the idea
that we're a part of this kind of like
company of actors is pretty cool well
hopefully Michael's could in some way
shape or form yeah right but you will
cross paths with Kanga conqueror you
know that valkyrie's gonna cross paths
okay and I will conquer him
I will show him my real conquerors the
money is on Valkyrie
um you know it's it's interesting too
like the BTS moments that we have kind
of a bit of of like movie Magic BTS
moments that we've seen from the making
of This sequel is there anything that
stuck with you that you think the
audiences might find fascinating to hear
about like what kind of goes behind the
scene Jonathan was telling me that like
all the body punches that they did were
real and they would have bruises that
the makeup guys can even have to like
put on because they were real because
they were real yeah yeah I mean they're
so there's so there's so much of that
over the course of the films I mean I
think like for example in the first one
we had one continuous fight and I think
something that audiences won't think
about is that when they're doing all the
cuts and in between that that's
happening in real time so as cameras
panning to one side of the Ring a makeup
artist is on this side of the Ring
rushing to get the cut placed in real
time before the camera literally whips
around and see so that sort of like
choreography and the dance that happens
in real time with some of these shots is
tremendous I it took me about a month
and a half to realize that Mike this is
the way that Mike was calling cut which
is that he would just do a very subtle
that
and I was it took me so long I remember
finally and we're like in a very intense
emotional scene and I realized that that
was the way he was calling cut which I
was like that's very cute well this this
film also left me in shambles I was like
y'all I needed to just see if I I didn't
realize how much darn heart I mean
there's always heart in them but this
one in particular I don't know if that's
you know Mike's stamp or J you know I
know the writing and whatnot but it
had so much heart to this film
yeah I think it does have a lot to do
with Mike I think I think you know first
and foremost these movies they are
really relationship movies that happen
to have boxing in them first and
foremost you know I think that's the
strength of these movies
um but I do think there is something
about Mike and what he wanted to say and
all of us he really invited us Jonathan
myself to implicate ourselves you know
inside of the narrative to really
wrestle you know in early conversations
and development he's like what do you
want to explore what do we want to talk
about this time and I think I think
because of that there is a tremendous
amount of heart because for all of us in
very different ways this movie feels
very personal yeah he said to me that he
worked out a lot of his personal stuff
yeah in the movie that he was going
through in real life which I liked I
liked hearing that because I could kind
of see that yeah in watching him yeah I
think we all did in in in different ways
you know I mean Jonathan's character is
really inspired by his his stepfather in
some ways I think you know there was a a
lot in terms of Bianca's struggle and
sense of identification with what she
does there were questions that I was
asking myself so I think there's a lot
that's really personal inside of it and
I hope that and I also think there's a
lot that is very Universal inside of it
questions that I think we all will be
asking ourselves and have asked
ourselves so I think that's where these
movies really sing Damian got me when he
said like what what are you know if
you're watching somebody else live your
life like you're saying and I thought I
said I was like
that would hit ooh bars
[Music]